one of our recommendations is that
hospitals are conflation zuv two
fundamentally different business models
and one business model when type of
business model we call a solution shop
which is a business that diagnosis
whatever your problem is and recommends
a solution so the big consulting firms
boston consulting group McKinsey &
Company our solution shops Cravath
Swaine and more here in New York City as
though will diagnose your legal problems
and recommend a solution and the
activities of diagnosing disease inside
of a hospital our solution shop kind of
business and those guys have to get paid
on a fee-for-service basis another type
of business we call a value-adding
process business where something is
wrong you bring it in and you fix it or
it's incomplete and you add value to it
and then ship it out the door so
manufacturing is largely value-adding
process business but education is to at
the Harvard Business School we bring in
every year 900 very defective incomplete
people and we adds value to them and
then we ship them off perfected to Wall
Street at the end of two years and and
in a value-adding process business you
can you can charge for the result not
for the input because the ability to
deliver the result is embedded in
process and equipment and in a hospital
the procedures that are administered
after a definitive diagnosis look a lot
like a value-added process business but
most hospitals because they they have
solution shop activities and value
adding process activities they mush am
altogether into the same organizational
unit trying to have the same metrics of
measuring quality and they just get
missed
but when when a provider separates those
two out they can diagnose so much better
and then administer procedures so much
more cost-effectively so this is a story
that was told to me by Dave snow who is
the CEO of a large mail-order pharmacy
called medco and David suffered from
asthma his whole life and asthma is one
of those diseases that's actually not a
disease wheezing is a symptom that at
least eight different causal disorders
agreed to share and so since he was a
young boy dave has been to specialist
after specialist after specialist after
specialist to try to get the right
medication that would relieve his asthma
troubles and each one of those would add
to subtract from multiply the
medications he was taking at one point
he said he was taking over a thousand
dollars of medications every month and
nothing worked so then he discovered
that there was an outfit in Denver
called the National Jewish Medical
Center and in clays language National
Jewish is a solution shop it's it's an
institution that is focused on dis on
diagnosing accurately pulmonary diseases
so they flew out there they administered
a bunch of tests that are standard for
them the tests materialized in 30
minutes the the results from it and then
into the room comes an endocrinologist
and ear nose and throat specialist and
allergist and a pulmonologist and they
sit down with Dave argue amongst
themselves about what the data means ask
Dave a bunch of questions discuss it
even more and then the leader of the
group said Dave okay here's what's going
on the reason none of those other
therapies worked for you is you don't
have those types of asthma
we think you've got this type and lucky
for you there's just a generic drug you
can take that will be effective for it
so stay here a couple of days we want to
expose you to the thing that induces
wheezing we'll take this drug and just
be sure that you're okay in bingo and
dave is he look back on that noted that
he had seen one of each of those
specialists many times in in his prior
treatment but he always had seen them as
individuals because hospitals are
organized to keep those individual
people independent to maximize their
flexibility and finally here was a here
was an organization that brought them
all together so then the second question
he asked was i wonder if this was
expensive or cheap to fly out to
national jewish bring the four
specialist together for a half hour and
my goodness it was dirt cheap and
chronic so that that it's a marvelous
illustration of how a business model
innovation can actually provide better
care at much lower cost